[Musique]
là
mine de rien la voilà qui remet yeux
h1 sonné
elle avait disparu le pavé de ma rue
et est tout bête
les refrains de paris avait pris le
maquis les forains l'orphéon la chanson
do maquis mais on n'oublie jamais le
flonflon qui vous met
le coeur en fait
et quand le mieux musiciens dans le
quartier bien revoir les anciens person
médias le public se souviennent
la chansonnette
tiens tiens
les titille les maquis c'est parti mon
kiki
la
chansonnette
après ce l'effet du corps car tous les
transistors
soudain serait
2 sous le ciel de paris un
accordéon joue la chanson de maquis
comme avant les ont cueillis par un
plomb plomb un têtard en blouson
d'un front de violer
fleurir sa part d'eau car malgré son
aigle au milieu du dos le coeur très bon
et sous ses cheveux grue
[Musique]
chansonnette
ce
là là là haut les coeurs avec moi tous
en choeur la
chansonnette
et passons la monnaie en garçon qui
connaît
chansonnette
il après sa moisson de reprennent paris
les forains l'orphéon la chanson de mc
it car on n'oublie jamais le plomb plomb
qui moud mais le coeur
ren fait
est il faut du temps c'est vrai pour
séparer le bon grain de
livrée pour comparer mais on trouve un
beau jour
sa chansonnette e dan
[Musique]